love this shot of grizzled Nick Fury
letting the beard grow out however is
this Nick Fury because this isn't how he
looked in the far from home post credit
scene could this be his scroll imposter
Talos back on Earth because the scratch
the injured eye is totally something a
squirrel could mimic also I'm curious
how much this show is going to delve
into the whole idea of super squirrels
squirrels who can replicate the
superpowers of others I think this
Show's gonna be a bigger uh political
conspiracy Thriller that just deals with
who people we already knew might have
been squirrel imposters since the
beginning it's also worth remembering
that in the MCU skrulls are not the
universally evil bad guys that they are
in the comics characters like Talos
Soren their kid their group of refugees
were actually good guys in the Captain
Marvel story so while there may be other
divisions of Scrolls who are bad guys
who are trying to infiltrate and weaken
Earth there's going to be a middle
ground group of Cooperative Scrolls who
are good guys
laughs
[Music]